- Kathia Gilder:
Bonjour et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro
de "Parlement hebdo".
Retour sur les temps
forts politiques
et parlementaires,
sous le regard
de notre invité.
- Alexandre Poussart:
On accueille François-Noël Buffet.
Vous êtes sénateur
Les Républicains
du Rhône et président
de la commission
des lois du Sénat.
- Kathia Gilder:
On va revenir
sur le projet
de loi immigration,
qui a été largement censuré
par le Conseil constitutionnel.
35 articles totalement
ou partiellement retoqués,
dont de nombreuses mesures
de durcissement,
qui avait été adoptées
sous la pression
de la droite.
Les députés ont voté
l'inscription
dans la Constitution
de la liberté garantie
pour les femmes d'accéder à l'IVG.
Le projet de loi sera soumis
au vote solennel
de l'Assemblée nationale
le 30 janvier,
avant de partir
devant les sénateurs fin février.
On reviendra sur la fronde
des agriculteurs,
qui se durcit.
Les raisons de la colère
sont multiples.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le Conseil constitutionnel
a censuré 40%
de la loi immigration.
Les mesures de durcissement
du texte ajoutées
par les sénateurs
Les Républicains
ont été en grande
partie retoquées
car considérées
comme sans lien
avec le projet de loi initial
de Gérald Darmanin.
- C'est une décision
aux allures
de sentence pour le texte
immigration.
Le Conseil
constitutionnel a décidé
de censurer
une très large partie
de ce projet de loi.
En premier lieu,
les sages
ont fait tomber 32
cavaliers législatifs,
des mesures jugées
trop éloignées
du texte original.
Exit le durcissement
de l'accès
aux prestations sociales,
du regroupement familial
ou encore de l'instauration
d'une caution retour
pour les étudiants étrangers.
Mais cette large
censure
est surtout un revers
de taille
pour la droite
sénatoriale, à l'origine
du durcissement de ce texte.
- Elle est contestable.
Finalement, le Conseil
constitutionnel interdit
au législateur
de prendre des mesures.
- Le Conseil
constitutionnel
a fait tomber
trois mesures sur le fond.
La tenue d'un débat
annuel au Parlement
pour fixer des quotas
migratoires,
le relevé de photos
et d'empreintes
sans le consentement
des clandestins
ou encore le changement
de procédure d'examen
dans titres de séjour.
La censure
de ces articles revigore
en tout cas les parlementaires
de gauche, vent debout
contre ce texte.
- C'est une bonne nouvelle.
Je me réjouis de cette décision
du Conseil constitutionnel.
On ne s'assoit pas
sur la Constitution
et sur nos principes fondamentaux.
Je suis heureux que le Conseil
constitutionnel ait rappelé
que la préférence
nationale
n'est pas
soluble
dans la République
et dans les valeurs
de la République.
- Le texte conserve
toutefois un large volet
de simplification
des procédures
pour les expulsions
d'étrangers délinquants,
notamment, ce que souhaitait
le gouvernement.
Malgré cette large censure,
Emmanuel Macron demande
à Gérald Darmanin
de promulguer la loi
dans les meilleurs délais.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Comment vous réagissez
à cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel?
C'est un hold-up
démocratique,
comme le dit Eric Ciotti?
- François-Noël Buffet:
Je respecte
la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel.
Il n'y a pas de difficulté
là-dessus.
En revanche, on peut
quand même s'interroger,
au-delà de ce texte lui-même,
sur l'application extrêmement
stricte des dispositions
de l'article 45
de la Constitution.
C'est celui qui est relatif
aux cavaliers législatifs.
Il a été modifié en 2008.
Il a été modifié
pour permettre
les parlementaires
d'amender un texte.
Il est indiqué
que l'amendement doit
avoir un lien
direct ou indirect
avec le texte.
On est sur une interprétation
très rigoureuse
de la première partie
de cette disposition.
On a 26 articles
qui arrivent au départ.
On estime qu'il faut
une politique migratoire
pour la France.
Donc, on complète
le dispositif présenté
par le gouvernement.
Toutes les mesures
qui sont proposées
sont relatives à l'immigration.
Personne ne conteste ça.
- Kathia Gilder:
Quelles conclusions,
au final?
Vous souhaitez ce durcissement
en matière d'immigration?
- François-Noël Buffet:
La conclusion,
c'est que les articles qui font
l'objet d'une censure
n'ont pas été jugés sur le fond.
Ils n'ont pas été
remis en cause
sur le fond.
Et pour cause, on a traité
que la procédure
et la forme.
- Kathia Gilder:
Ca veut dire
que le Conseil
constitutionnel aurait décidé
de s'en tenir...
- François-Noël Buffet:
Il a considéré
que le texte d'origine.
On verra très vite
que les amendements
ont été favorables
ou défavorables.
-
Kathia Gilder:
On n'est pas
dans la République
des juges?
Bruno Retailleau estime
que le Conseil constitutionnel
a censuré "la voix des Français".
Qu'est-ce que vous dites?
- François-Noël Buffet:
J'utilise rarement
des propos aussi forts.
Nous aurons
d'autres textes
et il y aura d'autres sujets.
La question qui est posée
de la permutation extrêmement
stricte de l'article 45
de la Constitution...
- Alexandre Poussart:
Il faut le modifier?
- François-Noël Buffet:
En tout cas,
il faut un échange très clair,
peut-être informel,
avec le Conseil
constitutionnel,
sur la façon
dont il interprète l'article.
- Alexandre Poussart:
La droite demande
au gouvernement une nouvelle
loi immigration
pour introduire
ces mesures
qui ont été retoquées.
Mais Emmanuel Macron a demandé
une application rapide,
une promulgation rapide de la loi
immigration initiale
qui a été acceptée par les sages.
Vous craignez que le président
souhaite passer
à autre
chose
et ne réintroduise pas
vos mesures?
- François-Noël Buffet:
C'est une crainte réelle.
Au bénéfice
de la décision d'hier,
le texte va être publié
rapidement.
Notons que toute la partie
procédure
dans ce texte est issue du Sénat.
Il est issu
d'un rapport
que nous avons commis en mai 2022.
Ca vient de chez nous.
De ce point de vue-là,
j'ai une petite victoire
personnelle.
Je crains
qu'il ne revienne pas
sur ce texte
et sur ces mesures
qui ont été censurées.
- Kathia Gilder:
Si vous remettez
en débat toutes les mesures,
vous convenez
qu'il y a peu de chances
qu'elles soient adoptées?
- François-Noël Buffet:
Il y a peut-être
des chances
pour qu'elles aboutissent.
Mais si on ne fait rien,
il ne se passera rien.
Si le gouvernement
ne le fait pas...
Une fois de plus,
ça fait l'objet
d'un accord en commission
mixte paritaire.
Majorité et opposition
se sont mis d'accord
sur ce texte.
Pourquoi ne pas le voter
une deuxième fois
sur une proposition de loi?
- Alexandre Poussart:
Comment vous analysez
les conséquences
à moyen terme
sur le quinquennat?
Le grand gagnant,
c'est le Rassemblement National?
Et est-ce que ça va tendre
un peu
plus les relations
entre l'exécutif
et Les Républicains?
- François-Noël Buffet:
L'événement
en lui-même,
sans parler du fond,
je pense sincèrement
que dans le contexte actuel
de fracture du pays,
il favorise incontestablement
le Rassemblement National.
Il ne cesse
de le dire
sur tous les plateaux.
Il a contesté
le texte et l'a voté
à la dernière minute.
Je pense qu'ils vont en tirer
un bénéfice,
ce qui n'est pas une bonne
chose
de mon point de vue.
- Kathia Gilder:
La prochaine étape
sur le sujet migratoire,
c'est la réforme
de l'aide médicale
de l'Etat, qui permet
de soigner les étudiants
en situation irrégulière.
Vous aviez trouvé,
à droite, un compromis
avec Elisabeth Borne,
pour s'entendre
sur une réforme
prochaine de cette AME.
Est-ce que vous pensez
qu'elle aura lieu?
- François-Noël Buffet:
Ca fait partie
de la discussion
du texte migratoire.
Nous avons sorti du texte l'aide
médicale d'Etat.
Promesse a été faite
par le gouvernement qu'un projet
sera déposé en début d'année.
Le ministre m'a indiqué
que c'est toujours d'actualité
et qu'il le ferait
dans un délai rapide.
On s'imagine
que c'est dans le courant
du premier trimestre.
Il faut travailler sur ce sujet.
Il y a un rapport
tout à fait intéressant
sur lequel on peut
objectiver les constats,
mais il y a des mesures
à prendre,
c'est incontestable.
La question est de rester
sur le principe
du soin.
Il n'y a pas de difficulté
là-dessus.
La question
du panier de soins,
de la nature
de certains soins,
est quand même posée.
-
Alexandre Poussart:
Est-ce que Les Républicains
doivent continuer
à s'accrocher à l'idée d'une
réforme constitutionnelle
sur l'immigration,
notamment pour permettre
un référendum des Français
sur ce sujet?
Bruno Retailleau
à l'air d'y
être très attaché,
mais vous n'avez
pas de majorité
au Parlement
sur ce texte.
Seul le Rassemblement
National est pour.
- François-Noël Buffet:
C'est la réforme
de l'article 11
de la Constitution
qui est en cause.
Le texte est déposé.
Il est déposé
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Il avait été retiré
pour des raisons
de circonstances,
parce que nous avions le texte
immigration qui était en cours.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Et les centristes
étaient contre.
- François-Noël Buffet:
Néanmoins,
on peut poser le débat.
On peut essayer de faire
avancer l'idée.
Le process
est en difficulté,
alors que le président s'est
déclaré favorable
à ça, et il est revenu
dessus après.
Toutefois, on a entendu
il y a pas longtemps
qu'il était de nouveau
favorable à ça.
L'espoir est possible.
- Kathia Gilder:
L'autre sujet
de la semaine, c'est l'IVG.
Sera-t-elle inscrite
dans la Constitution?
L'Assemblée nationale
a approuvé largement
la liberté garantie
pour les femmes d'y accéder.
Les débats ont été
assez âpres
entre la majorité
et la gauche
d'un côté, et les élus
LR de l'autre.
- La constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG
a franchi une première étape
dans l'hémicycle.
- L'Assemblée nationale a adopté.
- Un peu plus tôt,
le garde des Sceaux
avait défendu la nécessité
de faire entrer
dans la Constitution
la liberté garantie
à la femme d'avoir recours
à une IVG.
- La liberté
de recourir à l'IVG
n'est pas une liberté
comme les autres,
car elle permet
aux femmes de décider
de leur avenir.
- Sur les bancs
de l'hémicycle,
un large consensus,
malgré l'opposition
de certains députés
Les Républicains
et du Rassemblement National.
Un vote solennel est prévu mardi.
Sans surprise,
l'Assemblée adoptera
le texte.
La balle est désormais
dans le camp
du Sénat.
En février dernier,
la chambre haute
avait consacré
la liberté de la femme
à mettre fin à sa grossesse.
Une majorité
des sénateurs de droite
avait voté contre.
Le président du Sénat,
Gérard Larcher,
a réaffirmé
son opposition au projet
du gouvernement.
- Je pense
que la Constitution
n'est pas un catalogue
de droits sociaux
et sociétaux.
Je ne vote pas
par tradition,
mais je vous donne
un avis très personnel.
Je pense
que la Constitution,
ce n'est pas ce catalogue.
- Il est impératif
que l'Assemblée nationale
et le Sénat votent
un texte rédigé
dans les mêmes termes
pour que le président
de la République puisse
réunir le Congrès.
- Kathia Gilder:
Une fois adoptée
par l'Assemblée,
la réforme constitutionnelle doit
être votée
dans les mêmes termes
par le Sénat.
Le débat sera fin février.
Qu'est-ce que vous dites
en tant que président
de la commission
des lois du Sénat?
Vous êtes optimiste?
Vous pensez
comme Gérard Larcher
qu'il ne faut pas inscrire
l'IVG
dans la Constitution?
-
Alexandre Poussart:
Est-ce que vous êtes
contre ce texte?
- François-Noël Buffet:
On va commencer
par retirer les choses
sereinement.
Le Sénat, au mois
de février dernier,
s'est prononcé.
Il s'est prononcé
sur une rédaction
de la réforme
constitutionnelle,
qui est en partie reprise
par le gouvernement.
Cette fois-ci,
ce qui a été composé
à l'Assemblée nationale,
ça a été modifié.
- Kathia Gilder:
Donc ce n'est
plus le texte.
- François-Noël Buffet:
Non, il arrive
dans ces circonstances.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Une garantie
a été ajoutée.
- François-Noël Buffet:
Sur le plan strictement juridique,
l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse
est protégée
par notre Constitution
à travers une jurisprudence
constante
de celle-ci.
Il n'y a pas,
de ce point de vue,
de risques majeurs,
immédiats, imminents,
de remettre
en cause ce droit
qui est un droit
acquis et qui doit
être un droit absolument protégé.
Il n'y a pas de doute là-dessus.
Je n'ai pas d'hésitation
à dire
qu'il faut protéger ce droit.
Faut-il l'inscrire
dans la Constitution?
Sur le plan
juridique,
ça n'est pas une nécessité
absolue.
Mais on sent bien
qu'il y a une poussée
très forte de le faire.
Si nous devons aboutir
à quelque chose,
je souhaite
que nous y aboutissions,
à la condition
que la rédaction
qui soit obtenue
soit une rédaction parfaite
au niveau juridique,
de très haute qualité.
Je ne suis pas satisfait
par la rédaction
de l'Assemblée nationale.
Il y aura un débat
à la commission
des lois sur cette rédaction.
J'espère qu'on trouvera
le chemin
qu'il faudra.
J'indique quand même
que chacun
a sa liberté
totale de vote
et qu'il n'y a aucun contrat
pour personne.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Quelle serait
cette rédaction?
Vous avez voté
contre la rédaction
en février.
- François-Noël Buffet:
Les choses évoluent.
Je tiens pour acquis que le Sénat
s'est déjà prononcé
une fois.
Il s'est déjà prononcé
favorablement.
Il faut laisser
au Sénat sa liberté
de vote.
Il faut que chacun
vote en conscience
ce qu'il veut.
Mais je veux une base
juridique solide.
C'est mon rôle
de veiller
à ce que la rédaction
soit solide
et que le sens
soit parfait
dans la Constitution.
- Kathia Gilder:
Donc
vous n'allez pas tomber
dans le piège politique
que semblait vous tendre
Emmanuel Macron
en vous faisant passer
pour un parti rétrograde
sur les droits des femmes?
- François-Noël Buffet:
C'est complètement stupide.
J'imagine pas un seul
instant le président
de la République en être là.
Nous sommes évidemment
protecteurs
du droit des femmes,
mais le mettre
en doute, c'est quasiment
une insulte.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Donc malgré l'opposition assez
ferme de Gérard Larcher...
- François-Noël
Buffet: Je pense
que le vote sera serré.
Mais rappelez-vous
celui du mois
de février l'année dernière.
Le Sénat s'est prononcé
dans la liberté
de chacun.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Une majorité
de Républicains était contre.
- François-Noël Buffet: Très bien.
Mais pour moi,
c'est une condition absolue
que chacun
se prononce librement
et sans contrainte,
si je puis dire,
et que la rédaction
qui doit sortir
soit une rédaction
parfaitement équilibrée
et de très bonne
qualité rédactionnelle.
Une fois
de plus,
on ne touche pas à la Constitution
n'importe comment,
et on doit impérativement
être responsable.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Il faut enlever
le mot "garantie"?
- François-Noël
Buffet: Je pense
qu'il n'apporte rien.
On aura le débat.
- Kathia Gilder:
Même si vous votez,
le chemin législatif
pour ce projet
de loi sera loin d'être terminé.
Il faut réunir le Congrès.
On a déjà eu une date,
le mois de mars.
Emmanuel Macron
souhaiterait
que ce
soit définitivement
adopté avant la Journée
de la femme.
- François-Noël Buffet:
C'est un chiffon rouge.
C'est une forme
de pression exercée
sur le Parlement en disant:
"Dépêchez-vous,
parce que j'ai une stratégie
de communication derrière."
Soyons sérieux.
- Kathia Gilder:
C'est une erreur
d'avoir fixé une date?
- François-Noël Buffet:
C'est une provocation,
plus qu'une erreur.
C'est inutile.
Que le Parlement fasse
son travail correctement.
Quand le travail sera
fait correctement,
il sera peut-être
temps de réunir
le Congrès.
Respectons le chemin
parlementaire.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Un Congrès
de Versailles
début mars,
c'est peu probable?
- Kathia Gilder:
Peut-être plus tard?
- François-Noël Buffet:
C'est très présomptueux.
Peut-être plus tard.
En tout cas, laissons
le débat parlementaire.
Tout le monde le réclame.
Tout le monde veut
pouvoir s'exprimer.
Qu'on laisse
le parlement s'exprimer.
- Alexandre Poussart:
La crise agricole,
dernier thème.
Elle a secoué le Parlement
cette semaine, notamment
lors des questions
au gouvernement.
Les sénateurs écologistes
ont accusé l'exécutif
de faire de l'écologie
la principale cause
des problèmes actuels
de la culture française.
- La problématique
numéro 1
est bien celle de la faiblesse
des agriculteurs.
Votre gouvernement est le syndicat
majoritaire font
de la diversion en réduisant
la contestation
à celle des environnementaux.
- On a fait de l'écologie
un épouvantail.
Quand on vient
cumuler des normes
et des contrats,
comment voulez-vous
que ça soit facile
pour les agriculteurs?
On a besoin de réconcilier!
On est bien
dans une situation
où les agriculteurs
le vivent en permanence
comme une punition
ou comme une mise
en accusation.
On a un sujet d'image.
Il faut qu'on arrête,
dans les médias,
et à longueur
de médias, de dire
du mal de l'agriculture
et de montrer
une agriculture
qui n'est pas la réalité
de la culture française.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Avant d'évoquer
le fond de cette crise agricole,
parlons d'ordre public
pour les agriculteurs.
Le pays est vraiment bloqué
et Gérald Darmanin estime
qu'il faut laisser faire
les agriculteurs,
que ce sont des coups légitimes.
- François-Noël
Buffet:
Je ne suis pas d'accord
avec sa position.
Quand on est ministre on doit
faire respecter l'ordre,
quel que soit celui
qui manifeste,
qu'on l'aime ou qu'on l'aime pas.
Le fonctionnement
républicain
de ce pays
est de faire respecter
la règle.
Il y a façon
et façon de remettre
de l'ordre.
On peut le faire
de façon consensuelle,
trouver des points
d'accord,
avant de passer à des mesures
plus coercitives.
Ne mettons pas
comme principe
"parce qu'on est gentil
et qu'on aime
les uns ou les autres".
Mettons bon ordre là-dedans.
-
Kathia Gilder:
Vous n'avez pas
le sentiment
d'un deux poids
deux mesures,
quand on voit la manière
les réprimandes
à Sainte-Soline?
- François-Noël Buffet:
C'était légitime.
C'est différent
que de jeter
un peu de lisier
avec son tracteur.
Ce n'est pas
parce qu'on est responsable
de l'ordre
public
et qu'on ne doit pas prendre
en considération
les cas particuliers.
Les agriculteurs
ne manifestent
pas comme a manifesté
l'extrême gauche
à Sainte-Soline.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Sur le fond
de cette crise
agricole, ce mal-être
des agriculteurs
est causé par quoi?
- François-Noël Buffet:
C'est en réalité
une histoire ancienne.
Pour beaucoup de sujets,
la France n'a
plus de stratégie de souveraineté.
On parle de l'agriculture,
on pourrait parler d'autre chose.
- Kathia Gilder:
Donc vous accusez l'Europe?
- François-Noël Buffet:
Je n'accuse personne.
Je dis
que c'est de la responsabilité
des politiques
et de ceux qui dirigent
que de veiller
à ce que la souverainenté
de la France
soit absolument préservée
dans tous ces domaines.
Nous savons
que les choses
ne sont pas simples.
Nous avons besoin
d'avoir une filière
dans laquelle nos agriculteurs
puissent vivre
de leur travail.
Aujourd'hui, ce n'est pas le cas.
Pour une partie
d'entre eux,
ils ne vivent pas de leur travail.
Ils sont subventionnés
300 ou 400 euros
par mois, alors que le travail
est considérable.
Ce sujet, il faut le résoudre
de façon économique
avec une stratégie
économique
qui leur permette de vivre
de leur travail.
Y a-t-il trop de normes?
Peut-être.
Il y a aussi
une difficulté
d'avoir un discours
en France
et un autre comportement
à Bruxelles.
La question
était très pertinente,
de madame
la sénatrice mercredi
aux questions
au gouvernement,
qui a posé cette problématique...
- Alexandre Poussart:
Donc Emmanuel Macron soutient
le pacte vert à Bruxelles?
- François-Noël Buffet:
C'est un sujet.
On comprend bien
que certains agriculteurs
ou cultivateurs ou autres,
qui travaillent
dans l'alimentaire, ont besoin
de l'aide internationale.
Il faut une stratégie
de fond
pour que tout le monde s'en sorte.
Prenons en compte
les situations
et décidons d'une
stratégie souveraine.
- Kathia Gilder:
Merci d'avoir été
notre invité.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Merci à tous
d'avoir suivi cette émission.
A la semaine prochaine
pour les temps forts.